it's almost exactly a year and a half
since the cinematographer Helena
Hutchins was shot dead on the set of the
film rust and rather remarkably in some
people's minds today that production
will resume filming it has been moved
from New Mexico where that tragedy
occurred to here in Montana and in fact
the Yellowstone film Ranch is located
just down the road Beyond me there's a
gentleman in that blue car behind me
Who's acting as makeshift security not
letting anyone book the films cast and
crew passed and that cast and crew much
of them remain the same as when Helena
Hutchins was killed most notably of
course Alec Baldwin will reprise his
role as the film's main character he of
course was holding the gun which fired
the bullet which killed Helena Hutchins
and he and the films producers are still
in legal rankings there's at least five
outstanding civil cases and Alec Baldwin
and the film's armorer Hannah Gutierrez
read charged with involuntary
manslaughter in New Mexico those cases
yet to go to trial so there's still lots
of outstanding legal matters here but
one legal case which has been resolved
was between Helena Hutchins widower
Matthew Hutchins and the film's producer
they settled for an undisclosed amount
but one of the stipulations of that
agreement was that Matthew Hutchins
would become the executive producer that
he would see this film through and many
of the cast and crew have said that they
are doing this in Helena Hutchins memory
so filming set to resume today and
scheduled to last between 20 and 25 days